guys the boys club days are over
right it's gone time's up
i've done the research i've done the
math i've looked at the charts and women
are better at trading than men i know
guys you're gonna be
shocked to hear that but it's true i
mean let's look at the numbers
here warren buffett used to be the big
dog on top
he used to be the person everyone
referred to as the master trader
but he just lost 50 billion dollars as
coronavirus pummeled his stock
investments
meanwhile we've got an up-and-coming
youtuber that you guys have told me
to check out she's also on instagram and
she is just crushing it in the trades
her name is loving not working aka anna
macau
aka crypto queen i think it's macko
actually anyway she has this thing
called the two percent theory aka how to
go from 1k to 1 million in one year
using the exact method
i called the two percent theory and
she's got a little spreadsheet here
pulled up for us
wow it only cost two thousand dollars
guys and she will show you the secrets
of how to be a better trader than warren
buffett because look warren buffett he
makes a
a piddly 20 a year compounded over the
last 20 years now
anna macko she makes 2 a day
and she also says you can too using her
proprietary
color picker formula that's right let me
show you guys what this is it's a true
it's groundbreaking stuff okay so we
have two colors we have
red and we have green all you have to do
is pick the color of the day so how do
you pick the color of the day
it's really simple at first i was
worried that this was going to be a
complicated math formula
that you'd have some complicated
strategy or algorithm
that lets her win two percent a day but
guys it's simple
go over to the six hour chart okay we're
gonna do something else here we're gonna
clear
everything else out and just look at the
six hour chart
and is it more of a green day or is it
more of a red day
okay so we just spent a couple seconds
here looking at the six hour chart
no not not really right that's not
actually
that's actually her strategies looking
at a six hour chart and just deciding
if it's green you go green if it's red
you go red
uh well actually it is but
look guys hater all you want you can't
deny the results
and here are the results anna macko
she's someone who says you'll never lose
a trade look at this
look at this she shows you how to make
one million dollars in a year guys it's
so simple
you just start with a thousand dollars
and you play with leverage
and then you just make two percent a day
and never lose a trade over
365 days i mean it's very simple and by
the end of 365 as you guys know with
compound interest
you can take a thousand dollars and make
one million dollars if you just never
lose a trade and just make two percent
a day that's it that's all you have to
make and it's honestly you know it's
easy
it is it's simple strategy and you learn
how to never lose a trade again
never lose a trade again that's all it
is guys that's all it is
you just make a simple 274 dollars a day
every day
spend like an hour two hours a day every
day bang bang bang
hour two hours a day 274 dollars it's
easy
it's easy it's simple thousand dollars
for the year simple
easy life and that's something that's
pretty easy to achieve
wow pretty easy to achieve i mean it is
pretty easy when you find out that uh
how anna macko thinks of leverage
something like
100 leverage let's say bitcoin
moves one percent up you just made a
hundred percent of your money which
means you just doubled your money
and if it's one percent down then you
double your money too
but hang on what
it goes one percent up you double your
money if it goes one percent down
you've lost all your money you haven't
doubled your money one percent up double
your money
one percent doubt you double your money
both ways you double your money double
your money even if
it doesn't go anywhere you double your
money double your money double your
money listen guys the truth is anna
macko
is just ahead of her game and she
understands the stock market better than
anyone else and honestly if i were
warren buffett
i'd be worried about the power of two
percent compounded interest i mean
let's we're going to pull up a little
spreadsheet here we're going to do a
spreadsheet because she showed us how to
go
from one thousand dollars to one million
dollars in just a year but what i want
to show you
is how to go from one million dollars to
being richer than warren buffett
with the two percent theory guys and
that's ultimately why women are just
inevitably going to be better traders
than men because animako
is just going to come and beat up warren
buffett's returns i mean it's very clear
it's easy actually
and that's something that's pretty easy
to achieve guys it's actually easy to
beat warren buffett and that's just all
it is so
let's look up warren buffett's net
worth okay so warren buffett is worth
74.2 billion dollars pretty standard now
let's go and build a little
chart here we're gonna start with a
thousand dollars
okay so the only thing left to do is
just drag this down and find out when we
uh
start start getting richer than warren
buffett
so as we can see here boys indeed at
before 365 days we've made a million
dollars
but when do we get richer than warren
buffett that's ultimately the goal right
so guys at the two year mark we're now
worth a billion dollars
and we're just betting a cool two
billion dollars per day
hopefully we don't stop out using
leverage
and uh yeah we're just now now we're
making millions i mean every single day
so before oh my gosh we've already
gotten richer than warren buffett jeez
okay listen it only takes
915 days to become richer than warren
buffett now i know that seems like a
long time
it's only two and a half years two and a
half years
and you can be richer than warren
buffett who is how old again how old's
this old fart
89 years old you could be
let's say you start when you're 16 you
could be richer than an 89 year old man
when you're 18 and a half years old and
that is the power of the two percent
theory and that's why animako
is such a better investor than warren
buffett and why oren buffett is such a
loser
that's why he doesn't sell a course i
mean you ever wonder why warren buffett
doesn't sell the course because he's
embarrassed
he's embarrassed with these pitiful
returns
and that's just all there is to it uh so
just make two percent a day guys no
trades losses ever it's easy
go get the two percent theory two
thousand dollars no big deal um
and yeah have fun blowing up your
account and don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank you
[Music]
never lose a trade again and that's
something that's pretty easy to achieve